let's let's talk about this joe rogan
neil young thing i i i feel bad
joe i'm sorry that they constantly drag
your name in this stuff but let's be
real i mean joe runs the biggest show
when it comes to politics and culture
probably in the world it's the biggest
podcast in the world but in this space
he dominates and thus he's always going
to be he's on top of the mountain he's
going to be a target of this stuff and
as we enter 2022 uh the midterm
elections it's critical for the
establishment to push back on people
like joe so we have this ridiculous
story where neil young who is an aging
rocker who is not relevant 76 has he
sent a letter to his manager saying that
either spotify removes joe rogan or
removes all of his music apparently he
deleted the letter and quickly backed
down because spotify was like let me see
here four of your songs have broken 100
million uh listens and the fifth one is
at 73 let's keep on rocking in the free
world good song by the way hey i respect
neil young for his music uh uh but joe
rogan gets 11 million every monday
tuesday wednesday thursday so four times
a week
yeah in a month he's going to be
in a month in two months in three months
he's just massively outperforming what
neil young could ever produce
but this is the crazy thing
that that it's absolutely insane to me
that you have these the way described it
earlier neil young's the protest guy
he's supposed to he's supposed to oppose
the establishment and here he is being
like
we got to protect cnn we got to protect
the mainstream media
it's remarkable to me you know what it
says to me is that a lot of these people
you know i mentioned barry weiss and
bill maher and i'm i keep doing it and
it probably should move on but these
people know full well how bad the system
was they know people are suffering but
they don't care because it's their
market they're not willing to challenge
the establishment until you know the
polls shift in favor of uh i'm sorry the
polls shift against joe biden rasmussen
comes out and says the average voter
thinks the media's the enemy of the
people and all of a sudden they're like
uh
actually i've i've always agreed and
i've always sided with the independent
voices i don't think school should have
been shut down at all no yeah you see
what bill maher said when he was like
fouchy you can't just tell us what to do
in your lab coat it's like
wait uh
bill that was a that was in november of
2020 thought she said that
so these they know full well but i have
this i have this article here from cnn
on purpose i love cnn you guys know that
it's neil young's free world not joe
rogans remarkable it's an opinion by
jill what is it phillipovich yeah
yeah felipovich
so she of phil
what is this jill philippovich is a
journalist
based in new york the author of okay
boomer let's talk how my generation got
left behind is she a boomer
she basically writes about this and it's
funny because it's not neil young's
world he backed down he lost joe rogan's
winning you can't stop it it's it's this
is this is where we're at so neil
retracted his uh he deleted the letter
and his music is all still there i think
he realized that he has no leverage i
think i'm willing to bet he thought
you know i'm famous i got big music i'll
come out and i'll demand they ban joe
rogan for misinformation and then they
will and
spotify was like shut up old man right
like he didn't look at this ahead of
time like someone told him there's this
guy
we gotta get rid of you gotta come out
and threaten to take your music
somewhere else you got to choose
you know and it didn't work out at all
for them it flamed out and even just
from the numbers perspective that you
were talking about that's stunning those
numbers
i mean there is no argument there's no
debate about that speaking of facts in
truth that is a fact i bet he thought
that a bunch of other musicians were
going to step up with him and right yeah
i'm signing that
down
hundreds of thousands of millions of
views let's take it off kind of thing
right yeah he thought that he could
somehow join forces with spotify
employees that are triggered by
alternative opinions from from joe rogan
i'll i'll be honest
i'm willing to bet joe hasn't even
thought twice about any of this oh no
but i like to believe that he's sitting
there with his fingers crossed being
like please spotify break my 100 million
dollar contract oh yeah so that i can
get paid out instantly
host my show wherever i want well and i
should point out about jill in the past
she said uh during one of the
presidential cycles that white men
should not be allowed to run for office
again uh
among other things and jill should not
be allowed to write for cnn again right
yeah
and she's also recently talked about how
a lot of these scotus cases the current
supreme court is terrifying to her
um so yeah i mean is she
traumatized is she traumatized does she
need yeah you saw when brian stelter was
talking about that
journalists who got traumatized from
january 6.
it's it's crazy to me that you know uh
the way people feel uh
you know what
the mainstream media is threatened by
joe he's he's he's taken over he's
dominating the space long-form podcasts
like his like ours are growing and
growing and growing because they're more
authentic
we have politicians on this show
it's very difficult for them to lie or
weasel their way out of things so like
so you know uh we're gonna
we're gonna have some politicians in the
show
and i i commend them for being brave
enough to come on because i think you
know we had uh who was carrie lake yeah
and ian asked her about owning rocket
launchers and dmt and like
just like conversations and you know
what i can't stand i can't stand when
you're like watching obama and
they were doing this thing with him
where he answered questions on on reddit
or something and it's like
very clearly they go and they pick 10
very clean and very basic questions to
answer no no i want to i want carrie to
answer the question about owning a
rocket launcher yeah and that's like
alex man it's yeah the psychedelic thing
is super important for our leaders to be
talking about right now you can't like
you can look away from that as long as
you want but it's a huge part of
humanity and it needs to be addressed
politically authenticity that's what i'm
saying yeah and and
this goes to the other point that i see
a lot with journalists and we saw this a
lot with biden's press conference last
week journalists asked these such
i don't know unimaginative
questions it's so pedantic after like
five seconds and a lot of it is
questions that everyone knows the answer
to
biden has already stated his opinion
about x jen saki has already stated her
opinion about this
but you know they want their sound bite
and they want to ask the president for
yet another time though the only point i
will give them is no with joe biden who
knows he may change his mind if you
catch him at the right time and his
brain is not properly wired for that for
that day and his script is not up to
date you know what i just i can't handle
anymore is
the pr responses we know are fake
the questions from journalists we know
are fake i just don't care i don't
understand how there was a generation of
people boomers and to a certain degree
gen x who are like actually sit there
you know
attentive to a spokesman for an oil
company after an oil spill when you know
they're gonna lie when you know the
questions are gonna be boring basic well
they do sponsor the show so we've got to
be very careful but we do need to ask
these questions and i'm just like why
would i waste my time
it's kind of like if you're in going for
a family trip this metaphor came into my
mind and you're sitting in the back seat
you're a kid and your dad's driving but
then all of a sudden in the middle of
the trip your dad starts screaming at
everyone in the car and you're like well
i have two options i can sit in the car
and take it and then get to where i want
to go this this joyous thing i was
promised or i can get out of the car and
try and find my own way halfway across
the country as a nine-year-old so these
people watching the media are like on
the ride they've been sold an american
dream and they think that if they sit
here and take it they're gonna get there
they're gonna be taken to this promised
land it's that's not the way things work
they've been manipulated the whole time
the guy who sat in his basement watching
as ben shapiro said eating oatmeal and
watching matlock
you really think that guy was going to
do it for you it's really astounding and
they're flailing in the exact they're
flailing because they don't have any
they joe biden's not going to come to
the rescue kamal hair certainly isn't
going to come to their rescue if not
it's going it would arguably be even
worse you know and they don't have the
orator that barack obama was to at least
make them feel good you know i i he was
barack obama knew how to speak for sure
and he knew how to weasel weasel through
questions and things like that
i i will say that this administration is
so insane that actually the questions to
jen seki are are great even as boring
and as as as lame as they can be like
when when biden recently said that he
thought the midterm would be
illegitimate jan seki's response is uh
actually he he was talking about trump
he was he was criticizing trump you're
like dude we heard what he said you're
just lying now making the whole thing
worse but i'm glad she's lying because
now it's becoming so obvious to
everybody these are canned responses
with canned questions and it is waste of
your time to pay attention to these
people right and that's one of my beats
actually for newsbusters i watched joey
read show and i watched the white house
press briefing
and
and
some of the questions are pretty boring
and straightforward but i have been
surprised on certain days how yeah even
basic questions that journalists ask
elicit such horrible responses from jen
saki or whichever special guest that she
has on you know especially somebody like
jake sullivan or john kerry
it is truly astounding how terrible it
is and journalists i mean
you would say oh it's kind of just a
whatever question but it ends up
sounding like an amazing question
because their response is just so
terrible to these questions and they
constantly have to clean up for
themselves so they're not even trying to
set traps for them it's not even a trap
and they're somehow falling in i
remember this moment when uh the
deepwater horizon thing happened i was
working for these non-profits there's a
big oil spill i was in l.a at the time
and the response you get from these
companies is just like
you you learn nothing
they say nothing it is as generic as
generic can be and they may have well
have said
they might as well just said nothing
because there was no point in issuing
these canned responses you know we so we
recently had the ceo of gutter on the
show and we were talking about how they
banned this dude and he couldn't give me
a straight answer and he kept talking in
circles and finally i'm just like dude
this is bs you know i actually swore at
the time but we'll keep it family
friendly today and i was just like i
don't want to be involved in that kind
of show i don't want to sit here and
talk to people so that you know this is
obviously why people like longer form
podcasts that's why obviously why they
like joe rogan's show i don't even think
it's necessarily about joe rogan to be
completely honest i think he was first
in and best dressed and that helped him
i mean he's a famous comedian he's a
funny guy that really works for him he's
clearly talented but i think for the
most part it's he he basically you know
kick-starts this format of sitting down
with prominent people in a raw scenario
where they can't just avoid the
questions because he's going to be like
i asked you a question bro give me an
answer not always but often because
you're sitting here you want to get up
and leave in the middle of the show
that'll look even worse what are you
going to do in a segment like cnn where
they gave you four minutes it's really
easy to pat her you're way out of a hard
question
inflation is hitting what will you do
look we got a lot of problems in this
country that we're gonna be dealing with
and i want oh we're out of time thanks
for having me bye right and or they're
on a panel with 10 other people yeah and
that and so you get to speak once so all
told by the time you add up the amount
of speaking time you had
maybe a minute if that and or
you know or it becomes a shouting match
where there's a ton of crosstalk and
nobody can understand what is being said
i get i've gotten invited onto uh you
know fox news fairly often as of recent
and i was kind of like sure whatever i
guess it's like a couple minutes and i
was surprised how well those clips do on
youtube i think getting like you know
million or something views on some of
them
and then after a while i was just like
there's no point in trying to speed talk
my way through a three-minute segment
and i just do my show
and maybe it's good because a lot of
people say like you know get as much air
time as possible get on these shows
i don't know man it's just i'm so sick
of the inauthenticity just the fake
like pre-planned conversations here's
what we're gonna ask you about think
about your answer and it's just like i i
don't know man
i want i want real conversations i want
to i want to know what's actually going
on i think that's what people want too i
think yeah i think people want in even
some of us just want all of the above to
be able to have that option to
look at the digestible news that you can
read for example it takes you 10 minutes
or
see a really quick like youtube story or
like hear
you know news and headlines on you know
siriusxm channel and also be able to
have access to longer form conversations
and it's possible because of the
internet and social media that's the
reason this show is doing as well as it
is and other shows as well because
people have a thirst for that they have
a thirst for conversation uh and nuance
and you know just
all kinds of opinions thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast if you want to watch
live you can check out this channel
monday through friday at 8pm
now don't forget to smash that like
button subscribe to this channel and if
you want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time
you